c'est la première fois qu'il est invité
à touche pas à mon poste je vous demande
de faire un triomphe
monsieur cyril hanouna est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue comme tous
les soirs dans touche pas à mon
quel bonheur de vous retrouver tous les
soirs bienvenue vous êtes bien sûr des 8
oui dix huit vous êtes sur des week a
entouré de mes amis de mes camarades les
amours de mes bottés merci d'être là
bonsoir madame valérie bénaïm est avec
nous
dans la vie on va la vie humble avis
elle va magnifique jeu les week-ends
jeudi week-end formidable la toge bat
toujours un petit cadeau un petit
week-end un petit bouquet non j'ai eu un
petit bracelet il n'a pas osé encore le
un petit bracelet quoi gros reims ne
s'est pas foulée
[Applaudissements]
il est avec nous tous les soirs il
s'appelle jean michel mr et était
important qu'il soit là week end agité
j'ai été nord très calme parce que
j'avais ma fille mais ce week-end je
compte me rattraper une grosse soirée au
queen années 80 j'ai sorti mon avis
lumière et je vais envoyer du bois
j'aimerais bien elle est vraiment
j'aimerais bien avec vous je vous invite
c'est tout il y'a pas toi
[Applaudissements]
g
c'est parce que si vous voulez comme
tous les soirs je le présente et que ça
commence à devenir une routine pour moi
c'est un peu spécial c'est bien isabelle
vous êtes là et
isabelle morini bosc
à chaque fois j'ai envie de vous appeler
dubosc alors qu aucun rapport mais moi
je veux bien tout ce que j'aime bien
franck donc donc ça va bah moi ça me
tombe pas tout vous l'avez vu ce
week-end franck dubosc oui j'ai juste vu
mon mari on avait eu une dispute à finir
vous avez commencé une dispute
vous aviez commencé une dispute et vous
deviez la terminer ça s'est terminé
comme en août toujours à bâle moi il m'a
pas offert mascret si sûr et qu'est-ce
qui l'a pourquoi vous êtes disputer on
m'a alors vous savez vu nombre d'années
que je cumule au compteur on fait même
plus besoin de prétextes vous savez
maintenant pourquoi vous dise enfin vous
êtes en train de s'engueuler il me
semble rouis déjà ça s'entretient
on s'entretient en tout cas moi je
n'embrasse votre mari parce que
franchement il a du mérite
[Applaudissements]
intellectuel l'homme de cinéma
l'homme aux cheveux monsieur christophe
carrière est avec sa voix christophe on
a très bien défendu et on dit que vous
avez été voir des films non je suis allé
à marseille ce week-end sur les traces
de tournage à marseille sur les traces
de tournage d'un parent a french et tout
ce qui va sortir de ton nuit avec jean
dujardin et gilles lellouche à la french
premier film sur la manucure
[Rires]
mais on va aller voir ce film en tout
cas c'est formidable c'est bien c'est
vous le dites je pense que on voit du
bois là ouais c'était vachement bien
ouais celui père bien bas pour que
j'aille à marseille deux jours en
immersion pour voir où ils ont tourné
quand même mon sens c'est qu'il ya une
raison
mais l'analyse investi en immersion de
la dictée non non non non bah ouais non
parce que j'étais avec des tour
opérators mais des vrais marseillais
quoi tu menais ça s'est tournée quoi
voilà d'ailleurs je les salue s'étaient
tous fait assez fort parce que de
prendre le tgv
j'ai pas mal franchement c c'est fort
j'ai verde et là ce sont tous les soirs
et là c'est un bonheur de vous retrouver
quatre mois à venir partager vraiment
vraiment comment va pas tous très bien
ouais à travers embrasserait pour moi
avec plaisir c'est vrai ouais vous avez
fait quoi vous ce week end
je suis en train de lui trouver un
cadeau là deux visions
[Musique]
c'est bon pour le bol pour le patin je
n'ai pas dit le pigeon pour le bracelet
qua non est ce que le mien il est c'est
un aigle ne suis pas d'accord
voilà jean yves lemoine est avec nous
j'oublie
jean-yves cook donc on jean luc lemoine
c'est vrai que j'ai dit jean-yves parce
que à chaque fois tous les soirs de dire
jean yves vous avez envie de changer
j'ai envie de changer voilà bien normal
merci beaucoup robert jeudi soir et ont
peu près à ce moment et on mettra jean
luc savard jean-luc me ça va très bien
vous faites quoi en ce moment bas en ce
moment je prépare mon nouveau spectacle
et puis le reste du temps je profite du
fait que j de chercher un cadeau pour
fatou pour être avec fatou jean-luc je
suis vraiment désolé d'avoir fait cette
erreur sur le prénom moi qui ai vécu
tellement de charcuterie de nom et de
prénom de la part des gens m'appelaient
gadel longtemps fidèle à l'adage se
disait au téléphone je peux parler intel
on me disait c'est qu'ils et gad elmaleh
le gars disaient segade elle est donc
spectacle tout seul sur scène
non je vais avoir pris à partie gad
elmaleh justement en tout cas j'ai un
grand respect pour votre métier faire
rire les gens seuls sur terre c'est pas
évident non c'est un travail de tous les
jours mais
essayez un jour
[Rires]
jean yves le mouël
moi j'arrive
laura ma la grèce
c'est la première fois qu'il est invité
à touche pas à mon poste je vous demande
de faire un triomphe
monsieur cyril hanouna avec
[Applaudissements]
bien mais c'est pas grave pollution
c'est un vrai bonheur de t'avoir ici
sache que tu es ici chez toi je rêvais
de faire l'émission verte' de m'inviter
gala c'est cool c'est la première fois
que tu es assis à cette place mais c'est
vrai c'est un vrai bonheur de tahoua
[Applaudissements]
jean-louis dans le mois qui arrive là
j'essaie je te cache pas que dans
l'équipe
aujourd'hui ils étaient tous un peu fous
là il arrive pas l'habitude et voilà ça
leur fait quelque chose merci
aujourd'hui vous rêvez de quoi
aujourd'hui franchement way aujourd'hui
si j'avais un rêve
ouais ce serait de 2,2 de reprendre ma
place dans touche pas beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
bonjour mis la musique
à
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]